every single frame of a comic book  really expresses as much story as it  could in one frame you know there's a  dynamism and a sort of a strength and a  boldness to to the way comics are  presented to you and so we tried to do  that in our animation we did a lot of  animation testing and we found out  pretty early on they in order to capture  the spirit of the comic books we had  animate on twos and so what that means  is in a traditional animation where you  would see every frame change sometimes  we would hold frames for two or three  frames when is 24 frames a second  instead of doing all 24 you 12 and the  mind fills in the gaps between them it  makes it feel more graphic there is a  clarity and a crispness in that so we  latched into that as an aesthetic that I  think made it feel more like a comic  book  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]